the better Donald Trump does among
african-american voters the more race
obsessed the Democrats and their
shameless media enablers become when
young african-american leaders were
recently invited to the White House by
the president they were instantly
derided by the left it was not as
something it was a make America great
rally the use of young blacks as props
which really is an insult to them Oh
insults of M L really aren't those
racist sentiments by the way isn't it
wrong to lump people into political
camps based on their skin color or
believe that only authentic America
African Americans are the ones who
despise Donald Trump and I thought
stereotyping people based on their skin
color was the definition of racism and
why should a reverend be speaking these
terms at all by the way I think what
they're what's going on here is they're
worried about their prospects and so now
the left are engaged in a coordinated
effort to brand Donald Trump as a racist
we have a white nationalist president
who's a threat to American democracy
people know when you say nationalism
smart people know what that is a dog
with so forth and it's a wink and a nod
to white nationalism I know it sounds
cynical but this man doubled down after
11 beautiful people were shot and killed
while worshiping for what some ideal of
whiteness that donald trump represents
and spews out of his mouth every single
day yeah that's what Donald Trump thinks
about every morning when he wakes up
whiteness come on you're better than
that and then there is this tiresome
claim Trump knows the only way that they
can energize their bases through fears I
thought Sarah Silverman was supposed to
be funny oh well oh really then talk
about fear fear-mongering what was Oprah
Winfrey doing in Atlanta today if not
fear-mongering
I'm here today because of the men and
because of the
men who were lynched who were humiliated
who were discriminated against who were
suppressed who were repressed and
oppressed refuse to let their sacrifices
be in vain gotta hand it to Oprah she's
a great speaker but I kind of liked her
better when she was given away Toyota's
and refrigerators to try to tie the
candidacy of the Georgia Republican
gubernatorial candidate Brian camp to
the scourge of racism and even lynchings
come on Oprah it's dehumanizing it's
completely baseless
it's totally cruel and again I say
you're much better than that and you're
much bigger than that
and I'd also say that this to Oprah
Winfrey how is this living our best life
now this kind of broad brush race
baiting desensitizes us to the real
racists out there who should be
condemned and prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law when they commit
heinous crimes and use violence to to
hurt and main people of a different race
by the way what did camp ever do aside
from running against a black opponent
nothing for a taste of true racial
obsession and outright racism here would
have here what a few prominent Democrats
said this week that didn't get all that
much attention what do you think of cory
booker's and you didn't come out of him
and you feel fellow i what do you think
about him saying kick them in the shins
essentially start to get to that kind of
well that was Eric Holder Eric Holder
yeah sorry yeah I know they all look
alike no they don't
our state director is Indian American
but he does an amazing job our director
of all constituent services she's
African American but she does an even
more incredible job than you could ever
imagine
I still can't believe that comment all
right Yolo come on it's all raised all
the time and in Florida Project Veritas
caught a staffer of a Democratic
candidate for governor Andrew Gilliam
saying that they saying this about
gillum's promises and about the state
itself fairy tales in the modern day
begin with once I am ok ok now imagine
if a conservative staffer for Ron de
santis was saying something similar I'm
gonna be wall-to-wall news day and night
and he and the candidate would be
labeled as racists and apathetic and a
transparent double standard is what we
just showed you cuz you know they are
really not going to cover that that's
just some fringe guy making a video
Democrats like Gilliam and Stacey Abrams
in Georgia are featured in endless puff
pieces across all media and most of
these pieces focus on their race as
their biggest selling point for the
candidacy okay I assume they're about
more than that
they have views and they have ideas but
it's always about race and race for the
most part alone but black Republicans
like John James running for Senate in
Michigan or Omar could rot a Muslim
Republican running for Congress for
California's 52nd district they're
hardly covered at all so I guess race
doesn't matter if you're a Republican
it's not historic at all the reason
again for this leftist race baiting
Trump's policies are working for African
Americans and the results are now
beginning to come in Democrat sense it
they're losing their grip on the black
community black unemployment is down
black entrepreneurism is up and the
polls are moving check out this new
Harvard Harris Poll a year ago president
Trump's approval rating among black
Americans was paltry 10 percent today
it's almost triple at 29 percent and
look at this a year ago only 17 percent
of African Americans approved of the
president's handling of the economy
today 40 percent approve of his economic
prowess
and this may be the most revealing
number of all on the issue of
immigration 15% of black Americans like
Trump's approach last year not great
this year again it's almost doubled 29
percent approve of Trump's immigration
stance my friends you might not like
everything he tweets I get that but
Donald Trump is standing up for all
Americans he doesn't care about your
skin color it doesn't care about your
ethnicity or what religion you practice
he's about America and that is a good
thing and add that to Obama for a moment
because he's out there campaigning all
across the country aside from his
incredible example of being he's a great
father and in himself a historic figure
you have to ask this question what did
Obama actually do substantively do for
black America african-american wages
during his eight years were flat
Obamacare was a complete and total
disaster and he did little to protect
the black community from the competition
of cheap illegal labor hardly talked
about it do not let the race hucksters
convince you to embrace the failure of
the past for the Democrats this is not
about protecting minority groups
it's about regaining raw political power
even if it means turning American
against American and stopping the
economic revival we've seen the best I
think we've seen in decades across all
races and all ethnicities and that's the
angle